Peggy 18
hi I'm Leslie a producer on Assassin's
Creed unity the team and I are excited
to present the world premiere of our new
co-op gameplay for the first time ever
you can experience the open world of
Paris with up to three friends in one of
the most brutal chaotic time periods in
human history the French Revolution
today's mission takes place at the dawn
of the French Revolution with the people
of France are dying of starvation four
assassins will be playing together to
infiltrate a royal palace under siege
your objective is to assassinate the
Marquis a corrupt noble hoarding food
and help bring justice to the people
we've built the city of Paris to be a
truly open world entirely available for
you and your friends to explore the
result is an urban playground that's
yours to discover with seamless
interiors massive catacombs and
monumental scope and scale the mob
demands justice Unity's new massive
crowds are made up of thousands of
active ai's they'll react to players in
each other to help create a feeling of
immersion these chain reactions can be
used to your advantage
coordination is key when playing with
friends his heir assassination just
saved me from being discovered detection
would mean a completely different
experience in outcome
fascinating the guards inspired the
crowd to storm the palace by force
these massive crowds are but one of
Paris's inhabitants rival factions fight
for control in the bloody revolution
streets while we entered the palace to
the front gate two of our friends
managed to find another way in and
helped us just in time Unity's online
experience is at its best during those
split second moments of synchronicity
saving friends avoiding detection are
going all out in full combat that's our
target he's heavily guarded we should
keep exploring the palace and look for a
better opportunity to strike fortunately
one of our friends has used his lockpick
skill to open an alternate path in unity
you'll have multiple ways to execute
your strategy that freedom alongside
randomized ingredients such as guards
locations paths or rewards ensure each
new place tree was different
we need to hold the that was close
I almost got detected by those two
guards but my friend got to them first I
returned the favor by taking out the
last one with my new stealth weapon the
phantom blade this courtyard is called
the Jardin du Luxembourg is just one of
the many historical locations you'll
explore in the game from the nacho dom
cathedral to the creepy tunnel of the
catacombs you'll discover Paris in a way
you've never seen it before
thank you all for coming despite the
poor sports outside our illustrious host
the marquee wishes to assure you that
the rabble outside can
playing with friends means that combat
is cooperative deeper and more
challenging you can stake out large
areas plan strategize and take down much
bigger threats together together spare
me please
that's it experience the chaos of the
French Revolution with your friends in
Assassin's Creed unity thank you